تشيكي تشيكيز، صاحبة هذه
الدجاجات في تامبا فلوريدا، جديدة جدًا في
تربية هذه الدجاجات، لدرجة أنها لم تُطلق على
كل واحدة منها أسماء، فلفل، فلفل، فلفل، فلفل،
وفلفل، هل ترى
فرقًا، ولكن حتى المبتدئة تعرف أنه من
المفترض أن يركض الدجاج من أجلها.  الطعام، لذا
صُدمت بريانا أنطوانيت لماذا
لا
تتحركون مرحبًا عندما
تجمدت دجاجاتها الخمس في نفس الوقت وبقيت
مشلولة لأكثر من دقيقتين، ما الذي
كان فكرتك المباشرة عندما
تجمدت، اعتقدت أن يسوع كان يعود،
ما تشهده في ذلك  الفيديو عبارة عن
نوبة ذعر حية، ما يحدث
الآن، الدجاج على الإنترنت لديه
نظريات سألها الناس هل حاولت
فصلهم وتوصيلهم مرة أخرى،
ذكرنا بمختبر أسود يُدعى
مافريك الذي تجمد عندما واجه
خمسة قطط سوداء خشبية زينة في الحديقة
مافريك كان هذا  سلوك الإشارة الغريزي
يشير إلى الفريسة حتى أخيرًا،
لا بأس، تم
فك تجميد ذيل المتأنق مافريك أولاً كما هو الحال بالنسبة
للدجاج المشلول عندما صرخت بانا من أجل خطيبها،
قاموا فجأة
بفك تجميد
نيك، ما الذي نعرفه الآن وما
تمكن خطيبي من اكتشافه في الشجرة
أعلاه هو  صقر، لقد قتل هذا الصقر
أربعة من دجاجاتهم، لقد قاموا بربط
خط السمك فوق السياج لإبقاء
الصقر بعيدًا عن طريق الوقوف بلا حراك،
إنهم يحاولون أن يكونوا غير مرئيين، هل هذا
ما يقصدونه بتمثيل الدجاج، هل
فعلت شيئًا جنس CNN ماذا  نيويورك
يا إلهي